انا اسود ابيض امامي حق حق خطا لا يمكن
يعمل فيه لذلك دفعت الثمان قال دفعتها في
اشياء كثيره
[موسيقى]
نفسك شيخ
ون ان النشره تكون حسب توجه السياسه
الكويتيه واسلوبها واحنا
لا نذيع الا ما ياتي من الاذاعه
[موسيقى]
الحالي
29 حاله وفاه خلال العام الماضي نتيجه
لتعاطي المخدرات
[موسيقى]
كنت اتخيل دائما ان يجب ان يكون فيلم
يستحق ان يعرض في كل انحاء العالم
عن السيره النبويه وعن الاسلام
باسلوب سينمائي متطور في تكنيك وفي مجاميع
وفي قدرات عائله العقاد لما نيجي الكويت
فقط في الكويت
في لقاءاته يقول شيء واحد
لولا محمد السنعوسي ما صار هذا الفيلم
[موسيقى]
ما هي النزاهه الشرف والنزاهه في عملك هو
الذخيره هو استثمار يكفيني انا اولادي
يذكروني بعد عمر طويل او بعد وفاته
شريف
[موسيقى]